[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROGER MARTINEZ: Whether
you're a gigantic enterprise
or a small team at a startup
or even a lone developer,
if you're using
Google Cloud, there's
one thing you all
have in common.
Your project will use and
depend on service accounts.
Everyone uses them,
but what are they?
What do they do?
Where do they come from?
And why should you care?
These are all
important questions
that we have got to
know the answers to.
I'm here to help you
figure out what's
what with service accounts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So service accounts--
what exactly are they?
To answer that, let's
take a look at something
you might already
be familiar with--
a user account.
[AUDIO OUT] account represents
Yajaira, the lead engineer
on your team.
She accesses the account with
the email address and password
associated with it,
and access to it
is shared with no one else.
[AUDIO OUT] IAM rules
associated with it
that grant it permission
to do some fun stuff,
like manage Kubernetes clusters,
create compute instances,
and configure monitoring
on the project.
As long as Yajaira
works on the team,
she can do whatever
the IAM policy allows.
And if she leaves a
team, well, her account
would be disabled so that
it couldn't be used anymore.
That's a user account.
A service account,
on the other hand,
is an identity that a compute
instance or an application
can use to run API
requests on your behalf.
[AUDIO OUT] are a few major
differences between a user
account and a service account.
Like Yahaira's user
account, a service account
has an assigned email.
But instead of a
password, it can only
be authenticated using a
private-public RSA key pair,
and it can't be logged
in via a browser.
[AUDIO OUT] accounts typically
represent virtual machines
and applications.
And while user accounts
should never be shared,
permission can be granted to
users to impersonate service
accounts, allowing multiple
users to access everything
that a service
account can access.
[AUDIO OUT] accounts
are granted IAM roles
to perform certain actions
and access certain resources
in your project, just
like a user account,
although they're usually
executing automated actions
and might have multiple
processes dependent on them.
That means you'll need
to be extra careful when
you edit their access or if you
want to disable or delete them.
[AUDIO OUT] two types
of service accounts.
Well, first, there are
Google-managed service
accounts.
You might see these sometimes
referred to as service agents.
These are service accounts
that google automatically
creates and manages for
some Google Cloud Services.
For example, right off
the bat, your project
is likely to have a
Google APIs service agent.
This is a service account that
runs internal Google processes
on your behalf.
There could be more
Google-managed service accounts
that exist in your
project, but you'll only
see them in your IAM
policy or audit logs
when you enable an API or
a service that needs it.
[AUDIO OUT] service
accounts, you technically
can change and
revoke their roles.
But that's generally
not a great idea
because it could cause
some services to stop
working correctly.
[AUDIO OUT] type
of service account
that we have is a
user-managed service account.
This is a service account
that you explicitly
create using identity
and access management.
You choose a name and the roles
associated with it yourself.
[AUDIO OUT] into
any that you create,
user-managed service accounts
include default service
accounts.
These are user-managed
service accounts
that are created when you use
some Google Cloud Services that
are meant to help
you to get started.
A default service
account is created
for App Engine and any
service that uses App Engine
and for Compute Engine
and any service that
uses Compute Engine.
[AUDIO OUT] for those default
service accounts is typically
PROJECT_NUMBER-c
ompute@developer
.gserviceaccount.com for
Compute Engine and PROJECT
ID@appspot.gserviceaccount.com
for App Engine.
Default service accounts are
generally granted the editor
role on your project.
For production workloads,
this might be a bit much.
So it's recommended that
you create your own service
accounts for these services
and apply more restricted roles
to them.
How can we see these
service accounts
in our Google Cloud project?
If you want to see all of
the user-managed service
accounts that currently
exist on your project,
you can use the Google
Cloud console on their IAM
or through a CLI using
the gcloud command.
The command $ gcloud iam
service-accounts list will
nicely list your user
managed service accounts,
display names, emails, and
whether they're disabled.
[AUDIO OUT] see all of
your service accounts,
including Google-managed ones,
the command $ gcloud projects
get-iam-policy followed by your
project ID is your best bet.
This will spit out your
project's IAM policy,
the roles currently assigned to
the accounts on your project.
This is going to include user
accounts, user-managed service
accounts, and Google-managed
service accounts,
as long as they have
roles assigned to them.
[AUDIO OUT] have only begun to
scratch the surface of service
accounts here.
There are still
some other things
worth considering when we
talk about service accounts.
In this series, we're
going to learn more
about creating them,
getting rid of them,
effectively managing them,
properly securing them,
and using them for development.
If you like this video,
hit subscribe or leave us
a comment below.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]